millones de empleos en el país cómo ha
respondido donde primero dijo que el
virus estaba bajo control y que iba a
desaparecer por hombre cuando no fue así
que estuvo en televisión todos los días
hablando del gran trabajo que
supuestamente hacía cuando los
científicos nos querían dar información
vital cuando necesitábamos a los
expertos en los ignoró solamente cuando
explotó el cob y demás estado se le
pidió a la gente que usara mascarillas y
aún así miles cuando le preguntaban y él
decía simplemente es lo que es
pero tenía que ser así realmente no el
cob y nos golpeó mucho más duro de los
nervios somos cuatro por ciento de la
población mundial 0 25 por ciento de los
casos de kobe nuestra tasa de desempleo
es de 2 veces más que la del reino unido
más de tres veces que la de japón donde
dice que estamos liderando el mundo
bueno si usamos la única economía
industrial que tiene una tasa de
desempleo triplicar en tiempos así
la oficina web debería ser un centro de
comando bien lugar es un centro de
tormentas solamente hay caos una cosa
que nunca cambia en su determinación
ante evitar la responsabilidad y culpar
a otros nunca asume la responsabilidad
ustedes tienen que decidir si quieren
reanudar su contrato o dárselo a alguien
más si quieren un presidente que defina
el trabajo como horas al día viendo
televisión y pasando su tiempo en las
redes sociales él es su hombre y si
están tratando de entretener o de
reclamar pero en una crisis se cae como
una casa de cartas y el gobierno
responde a eso para acabar con él hay
que enfrentarse a los hechos nuestro
partido ha estado unido y estaba
ofreciendo una opción muy diferente muy
diferente una persona que irá a trabajar
una persona que tiene los pies en la
tierra y que irá a trabajar una persona
que tomará la responsabilidad que se va
a concentrar que va a unir y no a
dividir nuestra
opción nos ayudó a salir de una recesión
antes y puede hacerlo de nuevo
en 2009 obama y biden comenzaron con la
peor economía desde la gran depresión y
cuando acabaron se entregaron más de
seis años consecutivos de crecimiento en
los empleos él aceptó la responsabilidad
por la ley de recuperación crearon
millones de empleos y comenzaron nuevas
compañías en comunidades en todo el país
ahora él está comprometido a reconstruir
el país como bueno tiene un plan
detallado inteligente para invertir en
áreas vitales para el futuro e verify en
las finanzas para los pequeños negocios
en el planeta para combatir el cambio
climático rock una infraestructura
moderna que traiga al país la
conectividad y las inversiones que otros
dan por sentados y asegurarse que los
afroamericanos los nativos las mujeres
los inmigrantes y otras comunidades que
se han quedado atrás escuchas sean
partícipes de esta economía y de
nuestras
iovine quiere construir una economía
mucho mejor para este mundo cambiante
mejor para los jóvenes mejor para las
familias que trabajan y cuidan a sus
hijos para aquellos que han perdido sus
empleos y necesitan nuevos para aquellos
que quieren dejar de ser un daño
colateral de las guerras comerciales y
también para las personas enfermas y con
discapacidades mejor por un mejor
salario y con un acceso a educación y
salud incluyendo las drogas los
medicamentos por prescripción y también
un retiro seguro y también la salida
paga él no simplemente va a poner su
firma en un cheque y se los hará llegar
diciendo que viene de él él va a
reflejar esa contribución en esta
economía creciente francés y la
diferencia es total ustedes saben lo que
haría donald trump con otros cuatro años
estarían repartiendo culpas y lo que
haría
es reconstruir el país es nosotros
contra ellos
todos vivimos y trabajamos juntos en
este país es una opción clara el futuro
de nuestro país está ahí muchas gracias